so earlier you talked about Tyrion being
your favorite character maybe the most
easy character for you to write who
would you say is the most difficult
character right the most difficult you
point character to write is bran and he
has always been the hardest he is the
youngest viewpoint character which you
know is difficult in and of itself
because when you're writing a character
that young you can't simply write what's
going on
you have to filter everything through ok
he's 8 years old what does he understand
he's he's seeing this scene does he
actually understand what's what's
happening in this scene like when he
comes on Jaime and Cersei as well they
don't have any clothes on and they're
wrestling you know because an
eight-year-old has a different way of
perceiving these things so you always
have that issue and his language has to
be carefully considered what words does
he know how would how would an
eight-year-old phrase the sentence or a
9 year old 10 obviously he grows during
the course of the story then later of
course brand has his his traumatic event
and now he's not able to use his legs so
of necessity he becomes a passive
character he cannot get along anymore he
cannot you know climb a tower or or run
around the courtyard so you're reliant
on other characters to to move him about
or to allow him to move about and that
imposes a certain passivity on him that
can be overcome but it takes some
thought to overcome it and finally he
gets involved more than any other
character in the magical side of the
fantasy and magic is something that has
to be handled very very carefully in
fantasy especially alo magic fantasy
like mine allo magic fantasy yes just is
compared to most fantasies there's very
little magic and Ice and Fire
it's increasing with every book but even
at the end when it's going to be at its
highest it'll still have less than other
people have when they begin on the first
page so too much fantasy can overwhelm a
fantasy and too much magic and overwhelm
a fantasy and really ruin it so all of
these things make brand very difficult
to write and
his chapters I have to put together very
very very very carefully and they tend
to take me longer to write in the
chapters of any other character which
was not to say I don't love the
character and some of the stuff he's
getting in is is great I really enjoyed
writing some of his chapters and in
dance with dragons in particular the the
stuff when he when he gets far north and
that was the green seer and so forth in
the cave yeah